Let me go next to our caller from the two
zero three areaCode, who's calling today from
two oh three.
Hello, David.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Who is this?
So I am Joe Harris.
I'm from Connecticut, which is ude of Massachusetts.
But as only you would know, being from Massachusetts
is next to Massachusetts.
No one else knows where it is.
Connecticut's a great place.
It's a great place where a lot of people who
work in New York City live, in fact.
Yes.
Yes, very.
That's why kov, it was a little scary.
But now I'm out in Pittsburgh, so Udairi Barney
Way.
My big question was, as someone who's a younger
person, I'm not exactly excited about Joe
Biden, but so getting him as president would
obviously be better than Trump right on these
down ballot races in the Senate.
Do you think there's any way that Democrats
could take the Senate?
I see like Susan Collins, Maine, maybe that
on CNN, Montana and Arizona.
I think it's Martelli or something in Arizona.
Yep.
But do you think there's any way we can push
50, 51, or is that unlikely?
Oh, no.
I mean, listen, it's an up I if you said to
me I have to it's an even money bet.
Who do I bet keeps control?
I probably bet on Republicans, but there's
a very clear path for Democrats.
And it does include, as you mentioned, Mark
Kelly in Arizona.
You've got Cory Gardner, who who is potentially
facing defeat in Colorado to Hickenlooper.
In fact, it looks like Hickenlooper is going
to win.
We had some polling from Montana.
This has Steve Bullock could win there.
You I'm not going to remember all of them.
North Carolina.
You've also got Maine, as you mentioned.
So, yeah, I've outlined a path that is not
it's not overwhelmingly likely, but it's certainly
feasible for Democrats to take control of
the Senate.
And, you know, when I see a poll that says
Texas is tied between Trump and Biden, that's
the type of shift that would likely go along
with Democrats taking control of the Senate.
But all we can do is get out and vote and
we've got to make sure that we do that.
OK.
Yeah, because I, I have like the deepest level
of disdain for MS.
Mitch McConnell, like drops off from evil.
Amy McGrath and Mitch McConnell is another
example.
Exactly.
Even even like Lindsey Graham and South Carolina,
like ice, such deep disdain, he's like destroying
our country on purpose.
And I like seatback.
I so much that if he lost, that power would
be huge for us.
It would be.
Absolutely, yeah.
So don't forget, that's a good one.
Lindsey Graham has an opponent in South Carolina,
I believe.
Young Harrison, even though certainly it's
an uphill fight or something.
There's a lot of races here that we should
be looking at.
No question about it.
Fight every single one of them.
And it would be amazing, amazing to take control
of the Senate.
And because, listen, if Biden wins in November
and Senate control remains with Republicans,
that dramatically limits how much Biden can
get done in terms of major legislation.
Hopefully, he can still use executive orders
to reverse a lot of the atrocities Trump has
done.
But you're you're going to struggle to get
big legislation done, and that's why taking
the Senate would be just fantastic.
Well, yeah.
Then we can just push and push and just roll
over the Republicans.
Absolutely.
I mean, as I've said before, as I've said
before, we accept the other reason Progressive
should really want to take the Senate is that
we want.
If you don't want to put the cart before the
horse, a process that a dozen times this week,
if Joe Biden becomes president, we want to
be best positioned to force Biden to be as
progressive as possible.
If there's a Republican Senate, it's unlikely
Biden is going to be tested with any seriously
progressive bills if the Republicans lose
the Senate Democrats.
And in the House and Senate will potentially
pass some pretty progressive stuff.
The Senate is not super progressive.
Even the Democrats in the Senate are not the
most progressive people.
But we can put stuff on Biden's desk where
it's like, is he going to veto that stuff?
That's the ideal scenario where we can force
some stuff onto Biden's desk.
No, yeah, exactly, exactly.
That was that was my big question.
I'm a huge fan of yours.
Thank you.
All the videos, your you're awesome.
You're smart.
You make great points.
I appreciate it.
If you know what I'm thinking about, though.
Thanks for your time.
I'm glad you called.
Very much appreciated.
That is going to do it for calls today.
We're going to go to a break.
But I do plan on taking calls again in the
future.
If you were unable to get on today.